[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 8 le débat pour certains
neuropsychologue c'est une épidémie
silencieuse la commotion cérébrale et un
choc à la tête qui de manière répétée
pour dommages et le cerveau et cela
concerne aussi bien les professionnels
que les amateurs
cela se traduit par une perte de
déséquilibre somnolence et parfois
vomissements qui se transforme ensuite
par des maux de tête difficultés de
concentration et parfois perte de
mémoire de manière répétée les
commotions cérébrales eux favorisent
l'émergence de maladies comme alzheimer
ou des troubles du comportement
invisible à l'irm peu de personnes se
rendent à l'hôpital pour soigner leurs
blessures certains médecins estiment le
nombre de ces commotions cérébrales à
des centaines de milliers par an en
france et touche de nombreuses
disciplines comme les sports de combat
ou bien de contact comme le rugby le
football le handball mêmes l'équitation
le patinage comment lutter contre ce
fléau sans faire part aux amateurs pour
répondre à ces questions jacquet autour
de moi pascal giraud vice président du
comité ile de france de rugby mais
également francs que la cuisse arbitre
régional de football américain mais
également président du comité
départemental de seine saint denis
bonsoir à vous tous et merci d'avoir
accepté de participer à cette émission
alors comme nous l'avons dit ça touche
un peu probants énormément de discipline
mais en particulier des disciplines de
contacts et de combat faut deux
disciplines font partie notamment des
sports de contact nom est juste est un
sport de contact
c'est un sport de contact même supporter
de collision mais pas de contacts très
dire dans ce sens du contact
mais vous avez quand même des problèmes
les commissions du camp même et
justement est ce que pour vous ce n'est
pas un problème d'image justement de
parler de ces problèmes là de santé est
ce qu'on entend c'est terrain tabou
c'est non c'est non c'est absolument pas
un tabou ça fait partie donc sport santé
c'est très lié donc ça rentre dans les
principes effectivement de deux
d'apprentissage éducatif et puis il en
parle et c'est effectivement joué la
prévention c'est ce que l'on fait on le
fait par des journées sécurité ou pas
nos éducateurs nous dirigeants et si on
en parle tant c'est qu'on la fiche
donc ça veut dire que les gens
commencent à émettre des non
effectivement sur les symptômes des
commotions savoir ce que c'est qu'une
commotion à savoir comment on peut
effectivement ça peut être sérieux c'est
pour ça qu'on veut pas tuer la pratique
de notre sport qu'on le respecte
fortement qui tous les sports des rangs
des valeurs éducatives et donc il faut
en parler et en parler ça veut pas dire
que le problème est multipliée c'est la
communication qu'il veut faire croire
qu'il est multipliée mais aujourd'hui
déco nice on améliore justement des
connaissances et en travail et des
neurochirurgiens des neuropsychologues
qui nous aident effectivement dans
toutes les démarches donc aujourd'hui
dans le rugby il ya des protocoles qui
existent que doivent mettre en place des
entraîneurs
voilà la dure aussi à ça et d'ailleurs
on travaille sur nos méthodes de jeu sur
notre rugby de mouvement
il faut savoir que l'île de france est
pionnière dans cette danse est dans
cette manière d' approche puisque
aujourd'hui chez les jeunes on a mis en
place un rugby contact mais au toucher
qui permet effectivement de travailler
un peu plus le placage dans un deuxième
temps je les prépare nos jeunes par
rapport à ça effectivement il y en a
identifié les phases de jeu qui pouvait
effectivement poser problème notamment
dans le football
nous savons tout à fait le même parcours
parce que y'a rien à cacher fiancé c'est
juste faire attention à la technique
éviter les jeux purement on va dire
d'engagement physique et faire attention
aux jeunes à l'effort qu'ils font c'est
pour ça que dans la même discipline dans
le même modèle nous on a créé une petite
brochure qui ont distribué à tous nos
pratiquants et nos entraîneurs pour
mieux comprendre les symptômes et que
faire au moment où on peut détecter et
je vais tout symptôme quelconque
justement s'appelle a le plaisir du
joueur justement qui est ce contact là
un peu ce choc impressionnant mais le
contact est pas forcément tête contre
tête avec la commotion cérébrale
effectivement c'est une blessure du
cerveau par des blessures d'autres mais
c'est une blessure comme une autre donc
à part qu'il faut la prendre très au
sérieux parce que c'est le ça touche le
cerveau et donc puisqu'il faut éviter
c'est la répétition donc quand quelqu'un
une suspicion comme ici des commotions
pardon aujourd'hui nous on relève les
suspicions de commotions et ça va
forcément commotion mais ça nous permet
d'identifier des symptômes et d'éviter
que ça se reproduise derrière et on
protège le joueur qu'on protège notre
jeu est en fait on est là pour faire des
pour faire grandir les personnes dont
toute la dimension humaine on n'est pas
là pour leur faire du munichois quelque
part donc le combat oui le contact oui
mais c'est pas incompatibles il faut
bien mais il faut bien noter également
que le
dans les mails dans toute l'analyse qui
a été faite c'est pas tellement dans nos
sports où il ya le contact physique où
il ya le plus de commotions on est des
exemples parce que le football est un
cas très médiatisée aux états unis et le
rugby il devient de plus en plus en
europe
mais quand vous regardez les
statistiques aux états unis là à la
ligue les incite r assorti statistiques
le sport où il ya le plus de commotions
c'est le football féminin
ils vont interdire le jeu de tête au
football féminin aux états unis donc
voilà aujourd'hui les contacts les
contacts courriels plus de commotions
c'est quand la tête rencontre le sol
plus que le jeu alors évidemment on a
des des jeux où le jeu se termine au sol
de temps en temps
et bien c'est là aussi donc le nous on a
un engagement physique important et
c'est pour ça que tout de suite on a
pris la mesure en changeant les
techniques approche du plaqué pareil
nous le fasse de plaquer sont interdits
jusqu'en jusqu'à 15 ans donc si c'est
juste une prise de conscience de je
pense de nos sports et qu'il a de longs
temps qui fait qu' on fait attention et
justement cette prise de conscience au
justement faut faire un peu plus
attention
et on l'a depuis longtemps mais c'est
vrai qu'avec les évolutions de la
médecine les connaissances ça fait nous
des protocoles sur le fait à six est
temps qu'on commence à capitaliser
effectivement sur ces données là on a
travaillé sur d'autres problématiques
qui sont aussi liés à aux traumatismes
sportif est donc en fait on dit sur un
volet d'apprentissage mais on peut le
rencontrer dans la vie de tous les jours
bien sûr mais est ce que en même temps
on peut pas dire qu'on prend de plus en
plus conscience notamment des
conventions cérébrale
parce que peut-être que vous voulez dire
oui ou non parce que parce que le sport
devient plus spectaculaire plus violents
je crois qu'il n'est pas plus violent et
justement j'ai envie qu'il est plus
technique
aujourd'hui nos sports je pense sont
plus techniques on fait plus attention
justement à créer du spectacle et vous
parlez de d'évitement de genre de choses
et la rapidité du sport fait que ça
devient moins violent très franchement
je pense je pense qu'il ya d'autres
phénomènes il ya l'amdi d'être
médiatisation effectivement mon pour le
rugby on veut bien que le rugby est un
sport aujourd'hui on voit beaucoup à la
télé donc effectivement c'est ça
apparaît beaucoup plus on le met en
place sur les terrains avec les
protocoles commotion avec les cartons
bleus dont certaines divisions
carton bleu ça c'est nouveau c'est
depuis la rentrée
oui oui a été testé la sur le division
féminine la fédérale une et qui va
s'étendre à toutes les clubs de fédérale
1 les prochaines années bien aux
amateurs sur le sur le rugby fédéral
mais c'est une manière effectivement de
protéger le joueur de protéger notre
sport est ce que ce sera bien pris
notamment par les participants parce
qu'après tout ils sont là pour jouer
enfin qu'il faut qu'on sorte du principe
avant mots il est ko rigole on continue
nous c'est la santé le sport c'est la
santé ont construit des gens et des
êtres humains pour toute une vie
donc il faut pas perdre ces valeurs là
donc c'est cette noblesse la c7 ce
principe là qu'il faut défendre
il l'affiché c'est pas un problème mais
vous restez mm
non un petit peu géré d'iran depuis
début on a des médecins obligatoirement
sur tous les matches parce que il ya
plus de risques mais justement pour
protéger l'athlète et être sûr que l'
arbitre ou l'entraîneur qui a un doute
une suspicion sur quelque chose puisse
se référer un modèle médical en disant
voilà est-ce que ce qu'ils ont pensé
est-ce qu'il peut continuer à jouer donc
aujourd'hui ombre est danseuse dans
cette dynamique il n'y a pas de ya pas
plus qu'avant il n'y a pas à l'arrêt
aujourd'hui vraiment où on reste sur ce
schéma de protection et d'épanouissement
du joueur mais par contre une chose est
claire aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a une
meilleure connaissance à des symptômes 1
grâce à tous cette capitalisation est
aujourd'hui que ça soit dans notre vie
de tous les jours dans notre vie
sportive on sait identifier un petit peu
une suspicion de commotions et on peut
diriger après vers les bonnes filières
mais tout à l'heure vous avez dit
notamment que ça te présent compte du
médical changé aujourd'hui le jeu
commence à la musique à lui elle n'a pas
changé c'est fin c'est l'évolution
technique du jeu qui a fait que on va on
va plus vite on va sur des phases de jeu
qui sont plus dans l'ue débordement nous
un peu à la différence du rugby on a une
passe vers l'avant qui est de plus en
plus utilisé plutôt que le jeu de
contact
on n'ose y met au pied oui ok donc voila
mais la partie aux passes vers l'avant
donc plus aérienne prend plus
d'importance dans la stratégie c'est que
vraiment on est là pour vivre dans la
vitesse qu que dans la position de force
d'accord il y avait ce que justement
cette évolution
je pour justement des problèmes des
problèmes pour pallier des risques ni à
la santé ça ne va pas justement réfréner
risquer de faire fuir certains amateurs
qui justement sont maintenant parce que
ça préserve une identité de jeu ça
préserve une santé et c'est comme dans
tout aller il faut savoir évoluer quoi
pour pour part c'est pour continuer à
vivre il faut évoluer mais que dire il
ya beaucoup de choses qui évoluent la
réglementation évolue les contextes
évolue enfin il faut la société évolue
donc il faut prendre en compte
l'ensemble de ces éléments mais je
dirais que nous en ligne offrant sans
même plus loin à ce niveau là parce
qu'on sort des cahiers de de prévention
surtout sur tout ce qui se passe mais
sur les problèmes sociétaux le problème
lié au cannabis le premier à la prise de
substances dopantes ça veut pas dire que
dans le rugby il y a pas plus
qu'ailleurs mais simplement on reste sur
nos valeurs éducatives
école de rugby école de la vie non mais
toujours bien géré son nez des sports
qui sont relativement proches et
l'engagement physique fait qu'il ya
forcément le respect aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui est de ça va peut être un
pas important il doit respecter celui
qu'il est plus petit parce qu'il peut
malgré tout le mettre en difficulté ou
inversement
donc je pense que ça ça crée aussi un
nécessité de communiquer de rien effacé
de la vie d'hier voilà tout et vous
pouvez être confronté à des problèmes
tout le temps sur le terrain ou en
dehors
et nous on est là pour faire passer les
messages dire attention ça c'est bien ça
c'est pas bien et on pourrait vous en
sortir et c'est la solidarité qui se
créent dans nos sports je pense ce fait
que et pourtant vous en attendant on
dirait que les commotions cérébrales
dans le monde amateur ce n'est pas un
problème en fait ils viennent pas du
style la seule différence c'est qu'aux
janet
on aujourd'hui depuis depuis une dizaine
d'années il ya une médiatisation du
phénomène
comment dire commotion cérébrale il y en
a pas plus qu'avant il n'a pas moins
qu'avant sauf qu'on est allé mieux
connue parce que des médecins se sont
penchés sur sur le problème aujourd'hui
on laborde
on aborde nos jeux en disant bah oui il
ya code malgré tout il peut y avoir ce
procès pour les matic donc autant faire
attention tout de suite et ne pas
continuer dans des temps des démarches
qui était peut-être jusqu'à présent est
rodé mais ça ne va pas changer
fondamentalement le fils aurait xavier
nos règles évoluent je me tiens parce
qu'actuellement mais du carton bleu à
partir du moment où on dit qu'un joueur
quel suspicion ou le sort pour le
préserver ce qui se faisait pas avant
aujourd'hui on identifie beaucoup plus
et je vais à sapa tous les adhérents le
prennent bien traités aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui celle que c'est pour leur
sécurité et que c'est pour le jeu donc
il ya vraiment aucun souci là dessus si
on leur dit par exemple protocole
commotion chez nous c'est si une fois
qu'ils ont vu le médecin ces trois
semaines et qui est le médecin haïtien
impose ressenti d'une commotion trois
semaines sans jouer et s'entraîner c'est
comme ça et tout le monde n'accepte pas
ce que l'on sait tous on sait que c'est
pour la santé pour pour l'avenir non
franchement aujourd'hui ce qui était
peut-être pas le cas avant mais
aujourd'hui avec tous les gars ait
informations tout le travail de
communication tout le travail
d'explication c'est beaucoup plus
entendue et reconnu que ça soit des
entraîneurs qui veut garder leurs
joueurs leur meilleur joueur sur le
terrain b non une fois qu'il ya une
suspicion d'une blessure quelle que soit
la ville sûre il peut pas être au même
niveau
donc il faut effectivement prendre soin
de sa santé le sortir donc ça se fait de
plus en plus et il ya de moins en moins
de problèmes de fun avant comme s'était
pas complètement identifié la mesure du
danger était peut-être pas forcément là
aujourd'hui on la connaît principe de
précaution tous d'aller au delà de ça
oui c'est le le plaisir seulement le
plaisir il ya plus est je vous lis pas
ya vingt ans c'est comme si on parlait
du football américain en 1905 vous et la
tortue genre
les jeux romaine pour trouver français
ça n'existe plus aujourd'hui vous disons
des jeux autour des jeux de mouvements
de stratégie plutôt d'évitement de
gagne-terrain plus et ça ça change
beaucoup de choses merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté de participer à cette
émission et quant à vous je vous invite
à revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet et à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux
je vous souhaite de passer une agréable
soirée à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]